in this video I'm still on my current
segment which is where the Avengers are
currently at in the MCU however I must
stress that this video if the theory is
correct in it contains some major
spoilers to Avengers infinity war if
you're still with me we're going to be
talking about the first avenger that
dies in infinity war in this video I
will be talking about how and why
Loki dies in infinity War part 1 Loki
technically is not an Avenger
he's a revenger but at the end of thor
ragnarok it seems like he really turns a
page in his life bonding with his
brother Thor after the destruction of
their home planet as garden so why is
Loki now an Avenger and how does he die
let's answer those questions by looking
at this scene many fans believe that
this is Loki back to his old self
handing over the tesseract which is the
space stone to Thanos I however think
differently of this scene to recap a
little on Thor Ragnarok Loki had every
opportunity to run away but he chose to
come back to help Thor save Asgard
this in turn rekindled and strengthened
his bond with his older brother Thor and
again he could have even fled after the
battle but instead decides to join Thor
on the ship then what happens from here
is Stano shows up it's clear from what
we know that Fanus and the Black Order
board the ship and kill almost all the
Asgardians so how do we get to the scene
where Loki is holding the tesseract in
his hands over the dead bodies of his
guardians we know that Thor and the Hulk
fight against Thanos and they both lose
we know that the Hulk is terrified of
Thanos because he's seen his power we
also know that the Hulk's lost Bruce
Banner end up on earth and the sanctum
sanctorum with Doctor Strange and Wong
which leads us to the question how does
he get there if he was in deep space on
Thor's ship fighting Fantas here's the
theory on what happens after the fight
where Thanos and the Black Order kill
all the Asgardians or close to it and
essentially capture the Hulk Thor and
Loki Thanos will force Loki to hand over
the tesseract to him however Loki just
came back to help Thor save Asgard to
save his homeworld to save his people
and Thanos comes and wipes them away in
just minutes if he has truly turned a
page and is now
good he will want to defeat Thanos but
seeing how powerful is knows that he
can't also if you look at a spatial
expression in the scene it is not the
typical sly mischievous evil Loki that
we know he is clearly concerned knowing
that the tesseract is actually the space
stone which has the power to transport
people through space in an attempt to
give the Avengers a fighting chance
against Thanos uses the space stone to
transport the Hulk to earth once he does
this Thanos will attack him and take
away the tesseract at this point
danos is obviously not pleased with Loki
Loki has failed tano's from the
beginning along with others such as
Ronan to collect the Infinity stones for
him Thanos originally gave Loki his
sceptre in the first Avengers movie
which contained the mine stone did it in
which case he lost he also lost the
tesseract which is the space stone so
it's safe to say that Thanos is
infuriated with Loki Marvel and the
Russo brothers have been making Thanos
out to be the biggest baddest villain
the MCU has ever seen what better way to
show that than to have danos kill Loki
and make Thor watch at the same time
many people believe that this scene is
stano's torturing Thor I however think
it is Thanos forcing Thor to watch The
Black Order execute his brother Loki
having Thanos kill Loki does two things
one it demonstrates his power and
ruthlessness and two it'll give Thor an
even bigger reason to become stronger
than he's ever been to defeat Thanos
this is why Loki must die to send the
Hulk back to earth to be able to warn
the Avengers of Thanos as attack that is
coming and in doing so becomes a hero
and an Avenger does Loki really die in
Avengers infinity war Marvel president
kevin fake has already stated that many
of the main characters will die in
infinity war and will not be brought
back do you think Loki will die in
Avengers infinity war and if you do what
are your thoughts on it let me know in
the comments below and please be sure to
drop a like and subscribe to my channel
to stay up-to-date on Avengers infinity
war Marvel and all things superhero
thank you so much for watching and have
a great day
you